[Musique]
je bonsoir et bienvenue dans vos
conversations mon ami de ce soir est un
centriste en chef qui murmurent infamant
à l'oreille des manuels mâcon depuis
qu'il a fait alliance avec lui en 2017
que parler du maire de boué président du
modem françois bayrou dans la deuxième
partie de l'émission on retrouvera nos
décrypteurs l'écrivain mouche allemagne
et de rédacteur en chef politique
journal du dimanche david revault
d'allonnes avec moi s'intéresser à cet
antre du pur sous l'angle des remous
chemin de chacun des deux finalistes
intel qui n'est pas projet contre projet
mehr j contre temps roger ce sera
ensuite art de la carte blanche de
l'écrivain jean paul enthoven qui va
nous proposer de jouer au jeu préféré de
feu jean d'ormesson le jeu de la vie
psychique et on terminera avec mes
pépites dénichées ce soir par christophe
barbier
[Musique]
françois bayrou bonsoir bonjour ravis de
vous accueillir sur ce plateau alors il
ya une dizaine de jours sur ce plateau
même de nos décryptage tristane banon
vous rendez cet hommage voudrait qu'on
le regarde ensemble je trouve que le
parcours de cet homme est en tous points
exemplaire c'est un homme politique qui
a été le troisième homme faut pas
l'oublier
qui derrière a voulu refondre son parti
qui était plutôt en partie centre droite
et qui est devenu un parti centre centre
et qui a laissé ses ambitions
personnelles ses ambitions de chef
d'état de côté pour peut-être se rendre
indispensable par ailleurs
est-ce que c'est satisfaisant certes
françois bayrou un s'être rendu
indispensable
franchement si vous considérez le sens
d'un engagement
il ya aucun doute pour moi que la
réponse est oui c'est pas d'être
indispensable on n'est jamais
indispensable comme on dit les
cimetières sont complices alors d'être
gens-là 10
président de faire
se réaliser
quelque chose qui était
une recherche peut-être un rêve dont
personne ne croyait qu'il était possible
oui nous étions une petite poignée vous
les centristes oui nous étions une
petite pdf le modèle wi et
qui
qui m'a suivi et qui a cru avec moi à
cette utopie pour eux
mais qui était en réalité un diagnostic
absolument juste que nous avions vu très
tôt
que les deux tours jumelles autour
desquelles s'organise est la vie
politique française
le ps d'un côté et l air de l'autre que
ces deux tours jumelles étaient vides et
de l'intérieur 15h10 enfants mais on n'a
jamais vu ça donc vous savez très tôt
n'a parlé souvent dans ces époques là
c'était pour moi une certitude parce que
quand vous n'avez plus rien à croire
comme parti politique vous ne pouvez pas
exister un parti politique c'est une
ensemble une organisation une amitié ça
compte énormément
qui croit quelque chose en commun est le
jour où les deux mastodontes
qui avaient tous les deux des talons
d'achille
le jour où ces deux mastodontes ont
cessé de croire et de croire ensemble je
savais que moi que leur destin était
scellé comment vous avez su que ça
allait se cristalliser sur la personne
d'emmanuel macron bas c'était c'était
simple au début et mâcon quand il est
arrivé j'ai vu ça d'un oeil un peu
suspicieux parce que qu'on avait on
avait construit on avait construit une
aventure politique
je dis souvent on avait planté lavigne
préparer le sol des voeux défricher
tailler la vigne laisser grandir la
vigne et puis voilà que quelqu'un que
vous ne connaissez pas jeune
aventurier semblé t-il arrivée va
vendanger votre vie mais je me suis dit
et pour des raisons qui étaient
extrêmement précise que je vais vous
rappeler une phrase je me suis dit que
c'était pas le plus important le fait de
se retrouver à devoir tendre la main et
au fond
que cette aventure soit
portée à son terme par quelqu'un d'autre
pour une raison précise comme vous
souvenez j'avais été assez près du
deuxième tour en 2007 très près même
comme tristane banon le rappeler
est simplement on a failli gagner parce
que michel rocard a failli basculer et
nous rejoindre et puis l'a pas fait et
donc vous vous l'allaitez je mettrais
pour être le michel rocard qui vous a
maintenant je les fais pour être
cohérent avec ma vie parce que quand on
donne sa vie à quelque chose on doit
considérer que l'idéal pour lequel on se
bat et plus importants que les avantages
personnels ou que la satisfaction
personnelle ou que enfin quoi que ce
soit de personnel et comment vous avez
fait pour qu emmanuel macron au fond et
de la reconnaissance pour vous pendant
des années parce qu'en fait si vous à
vous voilà vous êtes aujourd'hui encore
un de ceux qui arrivent et je suis pas
sûr qu'on soit limité à la
reconnaissance non mais là je vais vous
avez su mettre de l'amitié de
l'affection changerait tout ce que je
vais vous dire un secret
très souvent dans la relation que nous
avons avec deux présidents de la
république
il ya une phrase qui revient que
parce qu'ils me dis merci d'avoir fait
ceci ou cela et je lui dis y'a pas de
merci entre nous parce que ça n'est pas
un service de françois bayrou à emmanuel
macron elle n'a rien de tout ça c'est
que ça c'est une aventure partagée c'est
un combat partagé
très souvent dit mais quelle est votre
relation avec lui est ce que c'est
paternel je ris parce que et vous allez
sourire aussi pendant très longtemps on
m'a dit avec giscard vous avez une
relation filiale g10 pas besoin de
relation filiale avec le président
giscard d'estaing parce que j'avais un
père formidable qui est parti hélas très
tôt et quand on me dit est ce que c'est
paternel avec lui je dis non parce que
j'ai des filles formidables éjectable
besoin de substitut mais c'est une c'est
une amitié de combattants
qui savent
ce qu'il faut traverser pour exercer ses
responsabilités
qui sont capables de décrypter les
enjeux et de traduire pour leurs
concitoyens quelque chose qui ressemble
à une espérance c'est exactement ça le
sujet quels conseils vous lui avez donné
pour le débat de la dame un soir je n'ai
aucune mémoire quand il s'agit de nos
conversations savait de c'est une
amnésie bizarre mais quand il s'agit de
vos conversations avec lui aucune
mémoire mais ce que vous faites partie
de ceux qui considèrent que le sujet de
marine le pen c'est la crédibilité et
son sujet à lui c'est l'arrogance c'est
ça qu'on entend partout alors je sais
bien que ça se dit tout le temps ou
souvent partout mais un peu moins ces
jours ci parce qu'il est allé au contact
direct se faire engueuler par des gens
je ne vais jamais à marseille que je
vais vous dire et si c'était pas vrai je
vous dirais le contraire je ne les ai
jamais vus arrogant spécialement pas
avec les gens du bas de la pyramide ceux
qui ont le pied dans le réel ceux qui
travaillent ceux qui sont arrogants même
si quand même quand on fait ce reproche
la me prouver qu'il n'allait pas trop
quoi vous paraît infondée oui
vous l'aimez vraiment voyage personnel
c'est pas en termes de l'affection
journée ça peut être aussi j'ai de
l'affection pour lui mais il n'est pas
vrai que moi en tout cas et qui je suis
assez sensible à cela parce que vous
savez les sauver les milieux d'où je
viens et que je représente
et c'est pas les milieux privilégiés
assez loin d'être les milieux
privilégiés je n'ai jamais ressenti ça
j'ai passé des heures et des heures dans
des endroits absolument improbable sans
aucune caméra de télévision où je me
souviens 2 2 soirées à la belle étoile
on était avec des bergers
des maires de toutes petites communes et
c'était tellement naturel est tellement
fluide alors qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir
qu'il montre dames en faut qu'il montre
le caractère crucial du choix entre les
deux projets entre les deux
personnalités le caractère excusez-moi
vital
vital du choix que la france doit faire
et ce choix là il est
probablement le plus le plus brûlant que
jamais un deuxième tour d'élection
présidentielle n'est offert pourquoi
vous dites plus que jamais parce que je
voudrais juste faire un conte par une
comparaison avec 2002 et elle n'est pas
terrible cette comparaison parce que le
1er mai 2002 vous en souvenez on est à
quatre jours lors de ce deuxième tour
jean-marie le pen jacques chirac avait
deux millions de français dans la rue
mais une mobilisation incroyable
et là maintenant c'est comme si le
levier des consignes c'est exactement
pour ça que je vous dis que jamais le
choix n'a été aussi crucial jamais dans
l'histoire on ne s'est trouvé aussi près
et de manière aussi éclatante parce que
maintenant on voit
hélas le drame ukrainien fait que on
voit très bien les menaces qui pèsent
sur l'europe on voit très bien ce que
poutine porte et on n'oublie pas que
madame le pen
tout le temps a dit ma politique s'est
trempé poutine oui sauf qu'on a quand
même tendance à l'oublier un peu en tout
cas certains français et beaucoup même
y'a bien au cou qui doutent du danger
que représenterait véritablement marine
le pen pour la démocratie pas si vous
avez écouté michel onfray ce matin sur
bfm tv on va l'écouter ans on a quand
même beaucoup changé il me semble
je trouve étonnant qu'on puisse faire
reporter les péchés du père sur sur la
fille je pense qu'une espèce d'extra
territorialité tous les partis
politiques ont changé sauf celui de
marine le pen le pen c'est marine le pen
elle a quand même dit que la shoah
c'était la plus grande catastrophe du
xxème siècle un pas la même chose que le
père qui parlait de durafour crématoire
du détail qui parlait même de la fournée
en parlant de patrick bruel j'écoute ce
que les gens disent je regarde ce qu'ils
font je me dis effectivement qu'on n'est
pas sur le même terrain on n'est pas sur
le même terrain françois bayrou quand on
écoute michel onfray ça vous énerve pas
du tout j'ai
pendant longtemps j'ai écouté michel
onfray et je trouvais que c'était pas
mal
mais que un
philosophe
ou se présentant comme telle soit
capable de dire que c'est pas du tout la
même chose alors que vous vous trouvez
dans une situation où vous avez pour la
première fois dans l'histoire depuis
trois quarts de siècle où depuis 80 ans
l' agression délibérée d'un pays
puissamment armée contre son voisin qui
n'avait jamais présenté ni la moindre
menace dit le moindre accroc ni la
moindre phrase n'est rien que comment
est ce possible de d'être aveugle à ce
point quand marine le pen dit
récemment 31 mars je crois quand elle
dit bah il faudra que poutine soit notre
allié et quand elle esquisse l'idée
qu'il faut sortir du commandement de
l'otan pour se rapprocher de poutine
alors
de quoi un philosophe peut-il considéré
qu'il y avait eu sur ce point évolution
favorable évolution positive alors
disons que je suis pas du tout
philosophe mais que en tout cas je je
crois qu'on devrait tous avoir repéré
les signes de ce qu'est le plus
dangereux pour l'ensemble démocratique
comme le nôtre pour un pays démocratique
comme le nôtre et pour un ensemble
démocratique comme le nôtre
cet entre-deux-tours consacre le succès
du troisième de cette élection il sera
d'ailleurs en majesté tout à l'heure sur
bfm tv il n'a pas pris la parole depuis
le soir du premier tour je veux bien sûr
parler de jean luc mélenchon et alors ce
qu'il fera penser que marine le pen
comme emmanuel macron fond
pour essayer de séduire ses électeurs et
notamment son voile vous les avez
entendu l'un comme l'autre à marine le
pen a dit qu'elle cible et l'uniforme
islamistes mais sans viser celle qu'il
portait et maniema coin fait carrément
une opération séduction devant une femme
voilée féministe la semaine dernière à
strasbourg au fond c'est une forme de
danse des sept voiles est ce que ça vous
inquiète pas c'est une blague qu'est-ce
qui est une blague face à marine le pen
il y a cinq jours 1 je crois que c'est
et chez apolline de malherbe a dit
textuellement que le
l'interdiction de ce qu'elle appelle le
voile c'est pas mal ça fout là ça rien à
voir le voile est interdit en france
depuis presque vingt ans
elle dit c'est absolument essentiel je
crois que c'est le que c'est l'adjectif
qu'elle a utilisés et installe
rétropédale non non ça c'était il ya
cinq jours je peux pas considérer qu'ils
aient des rétro pédalage une émission de
grande écoute
elle dit ça c'est elle a dit qu'elle
allait pas qu'il fallait pas être obtus
sur ce sujet elle a dit ça devant des
micros samedi ou dimanche
si vous voulez on sent on voyait bien de
convoquer des mouvements bien deux cas
mais je n'excuse pas l'intention
initiale parce qu'il y à des rétro
pédalage de quad encore une fois on est
c'est une question de civilisation mais
ça veut dire que mélenchon est au coeur
de cet entre deux tours oui comme je
crois pas croyez passard jeu non je ne
crois pas aux
à la segmentation des électorats
je crois qu'on s'adresse aux français
dans leur ensemble
donc c'est pas un peu les gens mais
l'ancien nom parce que les gens voter
mélenchon les beaucoup d'électeurs ont
voté mélenchon et dans un élan
remarquable les derniers jours beaucoup
d'électeurs ont voté mélenchon parce que
il estimait que c'était le seul moyen
d'avoir une présence de gauche avec les
guillemets comme on dit dans cette
élection est peut-être au deuxième tour
de l'élection
et puis donc simplement tout tout tout
opération séduction
ne me ne me paraît pas au moins efficace
je pense qu'il faut s'adresser aux
citoyens mais est ce que ça vous le
dites à emmanuel macron parce que les
opérations séduction on voit jeudi dix
jeunes je n'en sais pas ce que je dis
j'ai une amnésie parce que des
opérations séduction a donc à
l'attention notamment des écolos ils ont
fait manuel macro il y a consacré
carrément l'intégralité de son que je
vois c'est pas la même chose a dit ammar
c'est pas la même chose l'écologie est
qu il faut faire c'est pas les écolos
l'écologie n'a jamais été aussi écolo
les samedi dernier nom et enfin il a
quand même fait beaucoup de choses sur
ce sujet les écolos comme vous dites
c'est
un courant d'opinion l'écologie c'est un
grand problème pour le monde
pour pour beaucoup de conscience et
c'est un problème qui nécessite bah
écoutez le choix qui a été fait sur
l'énergie de produire de l'électricité
sans émettre de carbone c'est pas un
choix pour les écolos
d'ailleurs je suis pas sûr que ça les
aurait attiré mais sa passe est un choix
de meylan ce nom se trouve pas
représentés dans ce jeu ne vaut à mettre
sur le même plan l'accessoire et
l'essentiel le le le
le badin et le réel on a besoin de
prendre la mesure de cette question dont
les scientifiques disent et répètent
qu'elle est absolument essentiel
l'humanité a besoin de réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
singulièrement de co2 gaz carbonique
c'est un
c'est un devoir d'humains mais à cette
prise de conscience françois bayrou elle
n'aurait pu être fait politiquement il
ya déjà cinq ans et pendant les cinq
années qui viennent de s'écouler elle a
été fait et je suis bien placé pour en
parler
là la relance du projet
électro nucléaire de la france c'est la
réponse est en même temps les
renouvelables et en même temps qu'ils
sont mais vous ne pouvez pas on peut
s'arrêter une minute deux phrases mais
oui vous ne pouvez pas développer le
renouvelable
quiétude par nature et d'énergies
intermittentes
y'a pas toujours du vent il n'ya pas
toujours du soleil vous ne pouvez pas
développer le renouvelable si vous
n'avez pas à côté une source d'énergie
stable qu'on appelle pilotable pourrait
en ajouter ou enlever la seule source
d'énergie pilotable qui n'émettent pas
de gaz à effet de serre c'est le
nucléaire et c'est pourquoi le nucléaire
va se développer dans tous les pays du
monde dans les années qui viennent de
manière à peu près iman câbles et de
surcroît c'est un secteur dans lequel
nous avons une capacité une technicité
c'est un atout pour la france alors au
moins considérons que ça n'est pas par
opportunité qu'il traite ce genre de
sujet est ce que ça montre quand même
comme mélenchon a un petit peu gagné ce
premier tour il a fait une bonne
performance après je suis bien placé
pour savoir que les troisième homme
il marque des points on les ans les
cultivent pendant l'entre-deux tours et
après c'est moins facile qu'on ne croit
alors la recomposition de la majorité
macro nice maintenant j'aimerais savoir
si vous y comprenez quelque chose vous
françois bayrou alors je sais pas si
vous avez regardez ce qu'a déclaré
edouard philippe sont atteints dont le
figaro il a rappelé qu'en 2002 il avait
été l'un des artisans de la création de
l'ump et il vous a cité leur ai dit
françois bayrou disait si nous pensons
tous la même chose c'est que nous ne
pensons rien il est est il précisait
toujours important d'avoir en tête les
grands auteurs au delà du persiflage ça
vous inspire quoi un personnage section
à lui edouard philippe à leur endroit
qu'il a absolument raison dont pas sur
les grands auteurs ont peut être des
auteurs respectable sans être cité parmi
les grands auteurs
mais je suis absolument tu sûr que cette
phrase qui a marqué un tournant vous en
souvenez
était juste et donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut d'ailleurs non pas une majorité
d'un seul bloc i dont il faut deux
choses il faut de l'unité faut qu'on
travaille ensemble faut qu'on se
respecte faut qu'on puisse même avoir un
sourire les uns à l'égard des autres
comme il l'a fait
faut qu'on parle ensemble mais il faut
accepter ou protéger la diversité parce
que je ne je ne crois pas qu'un seul
bloc un seul groupe central opposé aux
deux extrêmes ça soit quelque chose de
sain vous allez finir par être d'accord
edouard philippe et vous ça a mal
commencé le quinquennat mais avait
peut-être sera-t-il d'accord avec moi
comme ceux que vous avez décrit est cité
alors emmanuel macron vivoux bichonne y
compris publiquement va regarder ce
qu'il a dit lors de son seul meeting
d'avant le 1er tour c'était le 3 avril à
l'aréna nos gouvernements se sont
nourris de talents venant tous horizons
et nous avons continué de dépasser je
sais combien cher richard cher françois
scherr stanislas cirque christophe vous
tant d'autres savent dès la première
heure vous avez considéré que ce
déplacement était important je veux de
manière transparente izan que nous
puissions conduire ensemble dans les
cinq ans qui viennent
une réforme institutionnelle qui
s'imposent laquelle donnera justement
une plus grande place à toutes les
sensibilités politiques à tous les
courants philosophiques dans notre
assemblée je sais cher françois que
c'est le combat d'une vie et donc je ne
l'abandonnerait pas
il pouvait pas me faire plus plaisir
j'ai pas de l'ordre du plaisir mais si
l'on vous c'est toujours politiquement
ça n'est pas là que je vais le plaisir
je voulais mais c'est une satisfaction
politique non c'est l'aboutissement
d'une réflexion logique et d'un
engagement déterminé
en ce qui vous concerne ça en ce qui me
concerne et en ce qui le concerne c'est
un aboutissement au moins pour lui
j'espère que nous pourrons aller plus
loin qu est-ce que qu'est ce que ça veut
dire vous voyez la société française
aujourd'hui elle est
explosé en
préférences différentes en mouvements
différents blocs différents en
philosophie différente et opposées entre
elles on a connu les gilet jaune c'était
une manifestation incroyable pour moi la
fracture la plus importante c'est la
fracture entre la base de notre pyramide
sociale et le prétendu sommet ou où sont
les politiques où vous êtes les médias
et en d'autres maintenant il ya aussi
les scientifiques et les médecins tout
le monde est dans ce et dans le même
banc moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est ceux
qui sont en bas comme en foot comment
peut-on faire pour
réparer pour cicatriser il faut
respecter les sensibilités différentes
et trouver garantir que chacune peut
être représenté nos institutions sont
rejetés parce qu'elles sont coupés de
ces sensibilités là et de l'expression
des français il faut donc leur faire et
aujourd'hui
je ne connais personne qui soit
contre ce grand mouvement le seul
mouvement politique était content
c'était l'ère mais je vous assure
comprenez moi sans que j'aille plus loin
qu'aujourd'hui signerait volontiers pour
que en effet ça au moment où ils s'y
opposaient nicolas dorment à même le
soir bonsoir
moi j'étais ému aussi par le match que
vous a rendu emmanuel macron est
exaspéré exaspéré parce qu'il n'a pas
fait la proportionnelle pendant les cinq
ans quand il pouvait il ya six mois
encore quand je le voyais que je
disputais avec lui sur ce sujet il me
disait je suis pas favorable bon alors
comment on va prendre cet engagement
cette fois bon c'est très c'est très
simple
j'avais adressé il ya plus d'un an une
lettre que j'avais fait cosigné par
quasiment tous les responsables de tous
les mouvements politiques de l'extrême
gauche jean luc mélenchon à l'extrême
droite
et à toutes les sensibilités du centre
et aux écologistes tous les mêmes vous
en souvenez des socialistes majeurs
comme françois rebsamen mêmes dlr
majeurs comme gérard longuet ils avaient
tous signé ce mouvement là alors à
l'époque
on n'a pas suffisamment tenu compte on
n'est pas allé au bout de cet appel mais
aujourd'hui comment voulez faire
autrement et donc ce qu'a annoncé le
président de la république c'est très
simple c'est un grand une grande
réflexion transpartisane on va pouvoir
traiter cette question est une autre et
après soit les assemblées tranche soit
le peuple tranche et pour ma part j'ai
toujours pensé
à tort ou à raison que c'était une
question qui ne serait définitivement et
justement tranchée que par le choix des
français c'est-à-dire un référendum oui
d'accord et alors vous avez évoqué tout
à l'heure la possibilité de vous
retrouver tous de travailler en somme et
même de ce sourire les uns aux autres
j'ai cru boire un demi sourire avec
edouard philippe mais si sarkozy venait
en plus le sourire serait et épanouie
chargerait ou carte le sourire
honnêtement je n'ai jamais discuté avec
les doigts avec
nicolas sarkozy de ce sujet
[Musique]
parce que pendant longtemps
on n'a pas abordé deux sujets politiques
comme ça
je ne sais pas si nicolas sarkozy veut
faire partie de la majorité aussi ses
amis veulent faire partie de la majorité
mais disons si on prend aujourd'hui le
périmètre de la majorité comme elle est
vous voyez bien que ça va du centre
gauche au centre droit c'est à droite
on peut avoir une organisation qui soit
une organisation souple unitaire mais
souple j'ai été secrétaire général de
l'udf et président de l'unef dans ma vie
dont j'ai une petite expérience de tout
ça je sais que ça peut marcher
si on est déterminé à ne pas se servir
de cette organisation pour des avantages
personnels pour préparer des avantages
personnels pour éviter les guerres de
clans et si j'ai mon bras dire sur cette
histoire on ne sait jamais c'est jamais
je prendrai toutes les précautions
nécessaires
pour qu'on accepte la diversité des
sensibilités et qu'on écarte les guerres
de clans dernière tout petit et
ses compagnons d'aventuré trop optimiste
à quelques jours trop beau dire ça y est
on a été bon et là on va gagner il reste
peu de secondes pardon mais
annonce que tout optimisme dans cette
période est déplacé une élection
présidentielle jusqu'à la dernière
minute les choses peuvent basculer parce
que c'est comme ça l'eau moments
dramatiques où le peuple choisi son
destin on ne sait jamais ce qui peut se
produire
eh bien merci en soi bayrou d'avoir été
avec nous merci nicolas domenach nous on
se retrouve dans quelques instants pour
la conversation avec nos dictateurs les
climats amrouche alemany et le rédacteur
en chef politique du vide et david
revault d'allonnes à tokyo
[Musique]